if Donald Trump thinks you were with him
you're the best you're a great guy it's
a terrific organization it's a
tremendous institution doing amazing
work if Trump thinks you're against him
you are a corrupt evil bad person and
it's all rigged for Hillary Clinton and
that is exactly what happened after the
FBI after what was a complete abortion
of an investigation that should not even
have been public to begin with but James
Comey FBI director came out and said
okay Hillary Clinton is cleared there
aren't going to be any charges period
Republican presidential candidate Donald
Trump goes back to it's all rigged Trump
saying that commis decision is proof
that things in Washington are rigged in
Hillary Clinton's favor saying the
following at a Michigan rally yesterday
right now she is being protected by a
rigged system it's a totally rigged
system you can't review 650,000 new
emails in eight days you can't do it
folks
Hillary Clinton is guilty she knows it
the FBI knows that the people know it
and now it is up to the American people
to deliver justice at the ballot box on
November 8th it's unbelievable
unbelievable what she gets away with
Hillary Clinton is the most corrupt
person ever to seek the office of the
presidency of the United States hard to
read it with a straight face the
investigations into her crimes will go
on for a long long time again Trump now
on this you can't review 650,000 emails
in eight days or whatever we don't know
that it was 650,000 emails and you
absolutely can if you use technology to
eliminate duplicates and only focus in
on ones where Hillary Clinton is either
sender or recipient that can be done but
even if the 650,000 number is real there
is no obvious rigging here Donald Trump
now has made it completely obvious that
the whole rigged election thing it's not
about whether the election is really
rigged as he sees it or through
gerrymandering or voter suppression it's
PR that's all it is Pat the guy will say
wildly o contradictory things depending
on whether or not it will benefit him
yeah and he really has no shame about it
as we can see from his opinions how his
opinions about the same people when they
seem to be Trump
Li's these are the best people around
and when all of a sudden they don't seem
to be friendly to trump these are these
are the lowest of the low
these are pond scum corrupt individuals
and it's Trump it's all for PR there's
no real value or meaning to this entire
rigged election thing I am getting to
the end of my Omaha Steaks family grill
pack which they sent me and I'm so
thrilled that Omaha Steaks is making
this program possible today it was
fantastic and as some people know
because my girlfriend is pescetarian I
was not able to share the sirloin and
the filet mignon or any of the items
with her so I grilled the other day with
my across the hall
neighbor who as you can imagine was
thrilled when I went over and said
listen I've got steaks and they're very
good are you interested
and he said absolutely and we went onto
the roof of my building and partook in
some of the family grill pack which AMA
Hass takes is offering for $49.99 this
is a big big savings you can go to Omaha
Steaks dot-com and of course you have to
use my code which is Pakman that's PA
que ma n in the search bar and then you
can add the family grill pack to your
cart
don't miss the deal Omaha Steaks comm
search for Pakman a PAA ma n in the
search bar 30 gourmet items for $49.99